so thank you yes thank you for the
introduction and yeah thank you for
having me here
that is wonderful I love drinking beer
so yes yeah so I would talk about
something that is not exactly data
science it's more like a type of thing
so how many of you here identify
yourself like me today scientists obtain
analyst or you know use Python for data
things oh good good
how many of you are like you know Python
developers and more like a development
side and you know yeah
so hopefully yeah it's a mix of
background but this talk would be you
know suitable for everybody so it's good
okay
so I'll briefly introduce myself well
thanks for the tradition but I'll talk a
little bit more I works in hotel bass
now and I'm also organizing a I Club for
gender minorities because I've really
worn the diversity in the business
because I've seen a lot of ladies they
have very good potentials but they're
just like sometimes a bit scared to you
know to pursue for the career so the
club is really helping so we have a good
community and also I'm a member of the
Python sprint so what are we doing is we
are contributing to the open-source
project which is the the reason why
you're here like yes you're learning
about open source libraries and Python
is an open source project so yeah so
please support over the source and also
I've contributed to pandas and also date
you too so if you get a chance go to you
know I think tomorrow there's a session
about how to contribute your first open
source contribution so please attend
that and you'll love it and also my
colleague want me to just give a little
you know yeah about we are hiring so I
like your data in a person and you know
the work for beyond data analytics we
are going to hire a lot of you know data
scientist data engineer so even though
if you're you know a technical they you
know they say engineer like please pay
attention and or talk to me afterwards
so okay I won't spend too much time
introducing myself and my company comes
now let's talk about the things I want
to talk about today
who knows about docker alright who use
doctor before you stock up before yeah
good so you already know about docker
which for me is always you know I
remember about a cartoon image of a
whale with the boxes so basically what
it represent is like we can ship our
application and whatever we with it like
in an environment that is the same
everywhere we don't have to worry about
it works on my computer but not work on
my colleague or the users computer and
also is like a VM but it's not a VM
because it's very lightweight so it's
it's perfect for this job so there's a
lot of users using it now and it's very
popular
okay that's docker but what about
terraform who heard about terraform good
so yeah terraform is an infrastructure
as code so basically what it does is I
would make it brief so for example if
you we are using a cloud platform like
for example
anywhere's or GCP or Sora we have to you
know when we launch an instant we have
to set up all the settings right how big
we want and I which region we want to
use it and maybe for example in my case
I would use GPU so I have to add the GPU
s cell rate of order if I'm using GCP so
so all these settings a bit you know
sometimes you know we make mistake right
we forgot oh we forgot to add something
you know the size it's not the right
size it's too small for my job and so
that's why it's good to have it as curl
so we can you know check or what have we
done wrong it's like we can debug it for
easily because every everything is just
there in a page and also it's very good
for you know you can kind of reuse it
and we can show it to your colleagues
and things like that
so how do I know about it because I'm a
data scientist I'm not a you know that
person but I always believe that you
know as a data scientist we have to
always keep learning and learn new tools
to help your job or help whatever
project you're working on so I had
overcome a challenge before because I'm
you know studying on Coursera and there
is a course about deep learning which
there was an assignment that you know
they are very nice they already put
their saying if you are using you know a
CPU to to train it it would take seven
hours for each each time you run it so
but of course we have to turn the high
perform reaches and all these like try
an error so seven hours is too much I
only have you know like the deadline is
tomorrow so no so I'm thinking oh maybe
I could use a GPU so I'm looking for a
solution like okay I'll do I have a GPU
in of course every ever laptop of a GPU
right well graphical unit so look it up
with oh my GB it's not enough idea this
is Intel or something like that but you
know tensorflow love Nvidia I don't know
why it doesn't work that well with Intel
and I haven't figured out an easy way to
work with that so okay I have to get a
NVIDIA GPUs I look at that one eBay or
something it's very expensive if the
husband pounds was like only for a
homework that's like you know that line
is tomorrow and I won't you know I can't
fire as I too expensive like didn't get
it in time so I think the best solution
is to go to cloud platform right so my
company is using a device but I mean I
I'm always a Google person you know I
use a lot of Google Dawson's thing so
yeah we've got have a look at the GPUs
GCB so I look at it and actually it's
not that expensive and they give you
free credit to try it oh so yeah why not
yeah but at the end as a signed out at
the end I have to pay like beforehand
before I can use their GPU but you know
okay so also is there's also a challenge
because the Kucera
when we submitted a homework they have
they you know they have lots of students
worldwide right so they have a robot
grader that they're doing a guy come on
like a robot grader who is grading your
homework but it's it's very picky like
if it's not the same environment he will
you know
you're just like some sometimes these
give you cereal Moscow note no reason
you you you you're sure that you're
you're correct but it's just give you
see remark so you don't want that to
happen
fortunately the TA in that course
they're very nice day you know created
you know a docker image you know the
environments gotta be the same so
talkers saving the day now but I just
need some adjustment because I want to
use the GPU it's okay
actually if I look at that you know I
pulled that from the the Aki github and
then you know I changed the dockerfile a
little bit I used the GPU version
instead of the CPU version so it's fine
okay so I have a plan now so how to how
to execute it so first I have to write a
terraform script so okay as I start
using terrible I mean now I'm in love of
it and of course you have to install
first and then you have to get the
Google API key
Google's like very nice like you can you
don't have to setup like too complicated
the only thing you have to setup is to
use you know to download that API key
and also you have to set up the SSH to
to the project so it it's it's very easy
like for me even though I'm not like you
know a very developer person then I can
still do it it's fine and also I have to
write a startup script because when I
launch the instance I have to tell that
to you know oh install the driver for
the GPU also you know install docker and
run that or come image on the docker hop
so I have to you know write that script
which is a shell script it's not too
hard if you use Linux or something and
also you have to build a docker image as
I said I did some customization I have
to use the GPU version instead so I have
to download the docker file I build my
own image and put it there on the the
you know the the docker they have a
docker hub is like github basically but
you can also set it up to link with your
github if you have a repla there it will
be the image from your
hup-ho every time you update it so it's
all to automate a bill so it's it's
super cool
I found it as less of a cool feature
because it will always be up-to-date you
don't have to worry about oh I forgot to
build it and upload it again
so yeah it's wonderful okay so when I
launched when I typed you know I'll show
you later like how I did it I type it
you know with terraform I just type
terraform apply but when I type it
what's actually going on so what's
happening is test there's a scripting
terraform which kind of say that you
know all this information how I want to
set up my instance it's already stored
there so if we use the script to you
know tell the API what to do like what's
how to set up so Google API caught that
script and it will launch the instance
according to the structure that I set up
in the terraform square so it will
launch the instance at the same time it
will run the startup script the script I
write we hopefully have time to show you
it would be you know install the driver
and he stole the talk and all these
things and and uh afterwards because
like is after it installed akka then it
will you know run the image like you
have used talker than you understand
what's going on like it was just so you
your your application is in the docker
image and now it's like after all the
script telling you to get it from Taco
it was just like put your application
there but it's like a you have something
and put it in the box
it's running it's good and um yeah and
then afterwards then you can because the
docker image actually it's a Jupiter
notebook so and you can customize it
actually there's a lot of you know
different Jupiter notebook on on docker
hub so there's a lot of official ones
like for example if you're using Syfy
they have one for Syfy you know if
you're using you know deep learning they
have the tense of the one and if you're
doing something very simple you want to
customize it yourself you can download
the minimal one and customize it
yourself so you can look it up on the
doc doc hub so yeah
the the juban ennoble will be running
you can just access the Jupiter Noble
using the IP address or if you want to
be fancy you can have your own domain
name right but I am not that fancy I'm
just used the yeah there IV address okay
so why like why doing all this it's like
it's you know there's a pipeline and all
these things oh why am i doing it why I
can't just you know just quickly quicken
and I have it running in that's fine not
really because as I said before it's
very easy to make mistake you maybe you
forgot what did i do last time I forgot
so it's better to have it in the code
and also when you're like writing a blog
a tutorial or whatever teaching a friend
it's like okay then your friend will be
like they they don't know what they have
done oh look at my mistake and then you
be like I don't know what you have done
so so yeah it's better to have it
written down so you can check it what's
wrong
yeah so it's like no hidden things it's
not it's very easy to spot the mistakes
and yes easy to start over over again
like for example if I the Egyptian opal
right so for example if I did something
wrong I screw up the setting or whatever
I want to start it all over again so I
can just you know launch the Eastern
again pull the image again so everything
will go go back to what it what it was
and also if for example if you started
the project and you work on it for two
or three days you want to put it down
for a while like you can save all these
things but you want to shut down the
instance the next time you want to like
um maybe after a month you want to Oh
run it again to like to pick it up from
there then you can you know launch it
again you don't have to you know or what
did i do before and knows everything is
here so we don't have to worry about
that
okay um I have lots of time so I can do
it demo and see okay so basically the
the demo I do will be from my github so
yeah so you can kind of go to my github
I'll show you the link afterwards I
sly so you'll be able to assess as I
said and I'll show you yeah my VM is a
bit slow oh yeah because I'm using
Windows happen oh and docker don't like
Windows 7 so I have to use dock it out
on a VMware which is a bit weird but
yeah and now is shouting at me for
whatever reason
okay it's the danger of a lifetime all
right okay so what's in here in the
directory actually there's oh it's too
dark
that's it so it's just more okay that's
not much I can do about it um okay maybe
oh good I don't use it that much you can
you can tell yeah yeah okay okay look at
this like we have it's okay okay now
yeah so we have three files the only
three files that you need for this demo
the other thing doesn't matter like you
only need this free to start with you
need a telephone file
you know something DF and you need the
JSON file that I talked about remember I
talked about there's a Google API you
know um lock in detail it's gonna be
there so that one it won't be on the
github because like you have to have
your own lock in detail I won't share
mine
hackers alert yeah so yeah and also um
startup script let's the script that
right for you know pulling the talk and
all these for the demo I don't use the
GPU because it would take a longer time
to run a GPU instant it cost you more so
so but it would do what it what the
startup script will do for this one is
like it will put the and download doc
and also put a docker image so yeah okay
so now I have this hair reform script I
have installed
sorry that yeah this here telephone
script and I've installed terraform
before so what you have to do is only
like
Tara from in it so it's it's like you're
you know I get rapport you can like you
need it first so yeah I stand holding
clock in I hope the Internet is fine yep
so it's it's good it know that it's a
Google because I made I think it read
the script and it sees a Google service
provider and is connecting to Google now
and now so all you need to do is like
tariff um apply but a lot of people the
practice is like they will look at the
plan first to make sure this is what
they want before they applied it because
it could be a disaster right if you're
working for something maybe like in a
company or something so you don't want
to do it but without checking so yeah so
it's like you get all the information
about what you'll be setting up for
example you know um like you know this
is the firewood hack so I attack it with
the fire was oh this is the fire wall so
this is you know the instance you can
see uh it would be a bank loan so
instance and you know all these it would
be the size will be this one you know
and yeah in the name and whatever is not
very unfortunate or the region if you
have a preference yeah I will be there
and okay so now we can finally applied
it so okay so and it would ask you again
so say right so nobody would
accidentally do it so you can
double-check triple-check before you say
yes and then they will do it so I can
show you what it does is actually now it
should be setting up an instance if i
refresh it now
okay yeah this so that's the instance
it's running so it really depends on a
style of script if you install a lot of
things in your startup scripts so it you
know it would be like this but when you
go to the IP address it won't be running
like us what do you expect so let's see
if our little tiny little to be the
notebook is it done yet so we just go to
the IP address it's not done yet so it's
to installing things so we're lift up at
the moment so any questions maybe like I
can clear some of the questions now and
then maybe yeah yeah the styrofoam swig
right I'll show it here maybe it's
easier to have you know the white
background here is the same thing and
yeah it's it again plus nope yeah okay
so yeah is um providers Google and you
have to set up a lot of them actually
what I did it's like somebody write a
very simple tutorial I would say that um
online there's a lot of tutorial about
using terraform with a diverse but not
that much
with gzp so I was struggling a little
bit when I set it up there is a guy who
did a very simple tutorial a blog post
about all this basic thing but a lot of
the thing that what it actually means
you have to go to Google and I googled
go to the GCP you know they have a
documentation and you read it and
understand like what what you can do
with the API and then you have just find
equivalent in the tariff um script to
you know to plug it in so it's a bit of
a you know hard to start with but once
you start it's like is you understand
the the logic and it's very easy yeah so
I have set up a fire war as well because
um I just actually this file would just
allow everybody to go in so yeah but I
have to do it yeah and this is yeah this
is the instance so this is the same
thing that you know when you type
terrible
tell from plan you will see all these
things so yeah it's a it's like a JSON
format issue thing ya know they want to
see the startup script but this one is
just download docker it's nothing fancy
but yeah yeah yeah so this was very
simple writers just I just you know used
the docker yeah
the ya know nothingness but I can show
you the real thing that I did before
like um if I go to my rap oh yeah okay
there's a lot of things right um yeah
this one is the one that I used the GPU
so the stuff should be more complex yeah
so it installed the driver for the when
we're talking about yeah the driver
accelerator which is the GPU thing that
yeah so it's you have to you know do all
these this ways you can find it on the
GCP documentation so that one is not too
hard you just need to find like where
this and like how to get it and install
talker and yeah this is more complicated
because um he's I customize it and you
know yeah and this is my image if you're
studying the same course as me you can
use it actually so yeah um okay it
should be okay cause this is fastest
morning yeah now we have a jiffy
notebook that's working yeah
[Applause]
but last time I forgot about it last
time I forgot that you know I haven't
sure how to cute it so I'd show you that
now no it's less I was like yeah he's
not working and everybody's just like
yeah and this then that's the end of up
no okay so Tara from destroy it will
kill it like um should be yeah so after
you have done with it of course you need
to save your work and everything because
everything will be destroyed and of
course you always ask you the second
time so make sure that you really want
to destroy it and yeah but you have to
save your work and you know if you have
an image maybe you have to you know go
there and capture the image and all
these so yeah it's um
okay it's destroying it is destroy
everything including the the fire water
I setup so hopefully it's fine
I'm a bit nervous when it's taking so
long maybe the internet like thank you
very long
oh my god I can't queue it now no yes
dude oh yes it's destroyed okay no III
don't have to worry about it cuz like if
you are running a GPU is does it could
cost you a lot funnier I said yeah so
okay maybe I will show you like now this
one should have nothing and give me like
a whatever area I like fall for I can't
find it or whatever
ah okay so this is low yeah
so now it's gone it's not there anymore
and yeah this one become you know
nothing so it's destroyed so everything
seems to work perfectly
do you have any more questions cuz I
have a lot of time left so yeah also
aware of services like elastic container
service ah yes
stuff like that that you can also just
launched up images without having to
install docker and all of that
yeah I believe is integrating better
with 8 of s that's why a lot of people
using it with a diverse I believe
because um my I have a friend like she's
a software developer she's using it with
a the best and she said that oh yeah
actually you don't have to if there's a
thing in a the best I guess you said
like you don't have to do it in the
stops where it's already there and
you're going to just attach your image
there so yeah I believe a the bestest an
advantage so yeah but I I did it because
you know I want to you know there's not
enough tutorial there for GCPs I tried
to you know challenge myself and how
other people want to use GCP so yeah
could you pass it yeah thanks for the
great talking cool live demo the
questions about collaboration so you
mentioned in the beginning that it was
also useful for collaborating with other
people how can you let one person access
it and still book it from everyone else
uh you mean the instance for the
instance that you can you know um you
can actually set up the permissions
because in GCP you can set up the user
groups and all this so you can you know
set up who can access it and who have
the rights to change it and but but in
my in my slide my point of like
collaboration is like for example if you
want to pass your work to your collie if
like for example you pass your project
to them and they know that how to launch
the instance again like maybe after like
after 10 years when you've already left
the company or whatever and yeah they
have it written there's it's not like
you have to write a documentation or now
you click this and now you have to like
type in there but yeah so that's what I
mean and I have a question how do you
persist data I mean also if you maybe
have different Jupiter notebooks and
yeah how do you do that in the Google
actually no idea in Jupiter notebook
like the content inside yeah no let's
say you have some embedding you save it
and how do you how would you persist it
yeah actually because this one is cuter
instance right so for the if the the the
you know the volume is inside instance
it would cured it as well so maybe you
have to set up a pipeline to store it in
another you know storage space like you
know data warehouse or whatever like
that suits your project so you can save
it there or if it's just you know if if
you're like me just using it for the GPU
right and you can just download it and
upload it again so
okay I have one yeah and so you were
mentioning collaboration before in one
of your slides how would you see
collaborating on using this set up so
how would you use it yeah yeah it's like
I said I can pass on my curve but also
like people you know they can you know
like modified it on top of your work for
example like you know actually I'm
collaborating with that that TA of that
because they're a course because you
know he builded a docker image you know
but I you know add things and I modified
it and because everything is written in
a code it's very easy you know to change
the setup so I can you know instead of
using just tends to flow tributon oppo i
use test vote GPU version you know which
of the notebook and you know if of
course he didn't her fun part but like
if he used a terraform to launch an
instant without the GPU a separator i
can change it to you know add a
separator and you know run the drive in
the startup script and all these things
so um yeah it's like code it's very easy
for collaboration cuz yeah of all these
advantages all right any more questions
it's okay if take you know we finish and
have lunch earlier so thank you very
much for your talk
[Applause]